let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
well good afternoon
welcome to episode 18 of
let's talk the tony michaels podcast
tony michaels here there's a lot of bits
of
news out there today
get to talk about them here so
let's talk
[Music]
so a few bits of news uh
to get started here before we get into
the big
big story the collapse or what seems to
be the collapse
or the start of the collapse of the
republican
party is uh
we got some bombing going on on the
other side of the world hamas
and the israelis are exchanging bombs
in what seems to be a hot spot here
which is not surprising um you know the
the
trump claims that he had peace in the
middle east jared kushner was supposed
to bring his peace in the middle east of
course
here we are um there hasn't been any
presidents or any diplomats that have
been able to solve this problem
and the real problem it seems like is uh
right-wingers fighting right-wingers
and you know there's a lot of innocent
people in between in the mix
um so there's that story there and we
will see more and more of that story
evolve and have more and more facts out
of there but
uh the one the one thing that we've seen
was uh
it seemed like hamas had uh launched
over a hundred rockets
into uh israel uh
and the iron curtain uh was
was there to help protect him so let's
keep all those human beings
safe over there um the next story the
next story is there was a committee
meeting today
about the january 6 seditious
insurrection that the former guy
had incited which he was impeached
for so they had a hearing about that
today there's a lot of news coming out
about that
but but
i want to talk about the big news of the
day which i
feel like this bit of news will have the
long lasting effects possibly a
generation
of conservatives or republicans or
you know nazis as i like to call them
nincompoop nazis so
last week i talked on this program this
radio show this podcast
this live stream there's a lot of
[ __ ] words for it
i talked last week about liz cheney and
what what was happening inside the
republican party with liz cheney
why there was a struggle in the
republican party with liz cheney
a lot of people disagreed with me uh
of my framing of it now
you know i i have to i have to say that
i i want everyone to understand
that liz cheney
uh getting ousted from the republican
party
uh is a great thing for this country
now in so many different ways and
there's a lot to unpack
but her standing up and and telling the
truth about the election
is a good thing that's not a bad thing
for her to
embrace the truth once in her life
but i guess that's the point that i was
trying to make is that this
really isn't about the truth of the
election
that's not what this is about this is
about trying to gain back the republican
party that they once knew
and that they want back and the reason
why they want it back is because they
want those corporate donors back they
want the money to flow again
i mean this is all about money to to say
that this isn't about money
is really boneheaded i mean they they
want the money to flow again
uh and the way that they get the money
to flow
is to decouple trump from the republican
party now
i i believe i believe that you know we
we heard news yesterday that there was a
hundred republicans
that are willing to go with with liz
cheney on this
so i believe that there is a uh a mutiny
about
in the republican party and this is the
beginning
of what we're going to see as the
republican insurrection
as it were because really they want
their party back you know they want to
go back to the old
the old sustainable [ __ ] the old
sustainable lies you know
debts deficits uh lower corporate tax
trickle-down economics
you know that [ __ ] that's what they
want to go back to that's much more
sustainable
and corporations are held a lot more
willing to give
money to those lies than the lies that
trump has and that's the thing here
everyone keeps calling the
the big lie as it were
the lie about the election and and this
dominion [ __ ]
and the voting machines and fake ballots
and he won
and they lost and dead people all this
nonsense
that's not the big lie it's part of it
big lie is donald trump that's the big
[ __ ] lie
and just for for liz cheney to go out on
the floor last night
had to give the cold hard truth to what
what people in this country would deem
the rest of the people who haven't come
to realization in reality
because that's really that the case here
that's who she's talking to
she's talking to these [ __ ] boneheads
that are going to these events that
that lin wood and mike lindell the mike
pelo nazi are having
and they're still spreading this idea
that donald trump is
actually the president
that's what liz cheney is fighting she
you know this
[ __ ] about you know legitimacy and all
that i mean hell kevin mccarthy came out
today
and in a press conference and said of
course no one's questioning
the legitimacy of the election then what
the [ __ ] are you doing
then what the [ __ ] are you doing but if
liz
cheney was such a truth hero and she
wanted to
to spew the truth and give the truth and
stand on the truth
and be coupled to reality and not given
to the whack-a-doos
like linwood and mike lindell the my
pillow nazi
into this whack-a-doo q anon stuff
well then where the [ __ ] was she back in
november
when the writing was on the wall when
they done lost two dozen
cases in court and it was clear that
there was no
path to the supreme court to overturn
the election
why the [ __ ] wasn't she on the house
floor saying this [ __ ]
then telling americans and constitu
republican
constituents that this was all [ __ ]
where was she oh well she was still
hanging on to complacency
with the former guy
so to make her out to be some kind of
truth hero and some kind of hero of
democracy
i just don't buy that that line of
[ __ ]
now i do on the other hand i
do think that it is very very very very
important that the old guard
cheney style politicians the
establishment or the old establishment
as it were
to fight for their party and that's
going to help our country
because it's much better having thin
veiled nazis as a
as opposed to full-on nazis what do i
mean by that
well these fascists have
for the last four decades have dressed
up conservatism with the
or excuse me fascism with a thin veil of
conservatism
they've done it for the last four
decades
is to put a nice little cute dress on
fascism and call it conservatism
and they use that as their weapon lower
taxes deficits debt
tea party spending
universal health care minimum wage
all these fights i mean jesus christ
even getting inside of a woman's uterus
for [ __ ] sake and inside people's
homes and their marriages
for the last four [ __ ] decades
they they put a nice little cute dress
on fascism and called it conservatism
for [ __ ] years
[ __ ] years well now they're
mad now they're mad that it's all out in
the open
and people like mike lindell that my
pillow nazi and lynn wood
are out there pounding the pound in the
streets
getting their voters who normally cheer
on
cheer on things like oh build that wall
instead of we got too much debt
lower taxes
so that's the problem here is the
republican party is trying to find
a way to continue as a republican party
in a sustainable way
and donald j trump is a bankrupt
piece of [ __ ] he bankrupts everything
everything he touches
turns to liquid [ __ ] absolutely
everything
why did anyone not think that he was
going to destroy the republican party
of course he was he still will
their only hope their only hope is to
have a leader
who can actually garnish support and
keep the name republican
and hopefully that the trump lodites the
trump humpers the cuban honors
the ninka poop nazis
peel off and start their own party with
the name
trump which i think is more likely
i really don't think trump likes to be
called a republican he could give a [ __ ]
less if he's called a republican
he would just love he would love to have
a big
building that said the party of trump on
it you know
puke his name all over the [ __ ] side
of a building like he's done
all these years he's probably got a
little sketch of it
on a napkin
of the party at trump headquarters
because that's how [ __ ] thin he is
how shallow this [ __ ] is is that
it's about having a name on the side of
a building
and probably nothing in the building the
building be [ __ ] empty
because he's a [ __ ] bonehead
but here we are here we are
we are talking about the republican
party
getting chopped in half which is a good
thing for america
so of course what liz cheney did was
good for our country
but i don't think her motivation
is for democracy if it was she would
totally resign
and leave the party if that's what if
that's really what's how she felt
you [ __ ] break she wants power power
and money
and she sees this as an easy way to get
a a power grab
and i i think this has been coming for a
while folks that uh
these establishment republicans the
cheneys the bush types
out there these never trumpers um have
waited for the time
where it was right where the q and
honors the
the the trump pumpers these ninka poops
keep moving the goal post keep moving
the goal post keep moving the goal post
and keep frothing up these these these
knuckleheads out there on facebook and
twitter
convincing them i mean jesus christ
patriot takes on on
on twitter has been posting videos of
not just mike lindell but lynn wood
he's been running around having events
at what seems like
senior centers and these people he keeps
telling these people that donald trump
is actually the president
and he looks like jim jones i don't know
if you've seen this [ __ ]
but this is this is i mean
i watch these videos that patriot takes
puts on twitter
and i'm like holy jim joe's [ __ ] it is
jonestown all over it
and i would not be surprised if we hear
len looney tune woods
opens up a [ __ ] compound somewhere in
a foreign country and is convincing
these people to move there
because trump and the military is going
to come and save them or some
wackadoo [ __ ] he is telling people
crowds of people and by crowds i mean
tens of people
and most of them are are crusty white
people who would have thought
he's telling these people that the
military's on standby
trump trump is is actually the president
joe biden
isn't the actual pr don't let your eyes
fool you
just a bunch of [ __ ] horse [ __ ]
and the only reason why these people
believe it is because they want to
they want to believe it they want
to believe this garbage want to believe
it
these evangelical crusty white people
old people
well i don't think that the
establishment
the establishment and what i mean by the
establishment is the old guard inside
the republican party thinks that's
sustainable
that that somehow jim jones jr
lynn wood is gonna be able to convince
an entire country
that joe biden isn't actually the
president don't let your eyes fool you
don't let those stimulus checks fool you
don't let hr one when they get that
passed
and the laws change fool you
so it's all just an act it's all a
theater act from republicans in the
senate and the house
and fox news and oan and newsmax
and it's funny because uh i i think it
was
myrtle beach south carolina was the one
clip that i seen today
it's on twitter i got it on my feed uh
and if you're not following patriot
takes there you go patriot takes there's
you a good
shout out um patriot takes stays up with
linwood stays right on his ass
um so if you need to follow what linwood
and that whackadoo is doing the best
place to go is patriot takes
uh because he's exposing these
[ __ ]
all day every day but the one clip i
believe
it's it's it's linwood and myrtle beach
south carolina
and he's he's spewing this he's puking
this garbage all over the floor
at this what seems like a senior center
or some [ __ ]
and uh and halfway into this thing this
one lady says
well then why isn't anyone doing
anything about it
this is driving me crazy like of course
it's driving you are
[ __ ] crazy if you believe this [ __ ]
this lady is at her wits in
about moving the goal post and moving
the goal post and moving the goal post
and that's what's unsustainable here
folks is they can't keep
keep moving the goal post and people are
just going to go along
i mean eventually you're gonna have to
drink the kool-aid with the poison in it
or not that's what you're gonna
eventually have to do
the former president of the united
states donald trump
is a disgraced two-time impeach piece of
[ __ ]
he's a treasonous [ __ ]
he tried to commit a coup with an
insurrection of his followers
at a rally in washington on january
6th when they were trying to certify the
results of the electoral college
because he thought and he believed that
his supporters believe
that the vice president crowns a king
and now he sits in his shitty diapers
playing golf and blogging okay
there's no chance for him to take back
over
anything anywhere he's
lucky that he's not indicted yet in
several different states and in the
federal government
him and his [ __ ] family
he's just lucky that that hasn't
happened yet
so this moving of the goal post is a
good thing
let them keep moving the goal post keep
moving it kicking the [ __ ] can moving
the [ __ ] goal post
good for you have fun
not having anything that you say come to
fruition
because these people who are following
this he's cueing on
these q and on maga trump and [ __ ]
[ __ ] that believe this stuff that
aunt sally and uncle ned says on
facebook
every single time it's wrong that's less
credibility less credibility less
credibility
less credibility less credibility and
it's not sustainable
liz cheney knows that
she knows it
liz cheney knows that this
whack-a-doo stuff is not sustainable
and she's trying to grab power at a time
when it seems like there could be
dissent
and by dissent i mean other politicians
there is rumblings that there's a
hundred plus members
of the republican party that are willing
to stand behind liz cheney
well there's one thing that cheney
chaney's love more than anything
and that's power grabs remember when her
daddy dick
was out to search for a vice president
for george
w bush he ended up being the vice
president
when he was in search of one how
convenient
so liz cheney is in search of the truth
well the truth might just be she'll lead
the republican party
because mitt romney tried it mitt romney
tried this folks
and he tried it all the way back in
january of 2020 when he voted to impeach
donald trump to convict him of his
impeachment
so if you want someone who was who is
standing against trump there's your
[ __ ] example in the republican party
mitt romney not liz cheney
which cheney was still going on and on
and on about the
the truckload of horseshit that they
were selling about the coronavirus that
led to hundreds of thousands of
americans dying
all the lies that this [ __ ] told
for years including
including the reason why he was
impeached the barismalai
she sold that [ __ ] down of course and
then in november and december
she was [ __ ] complacent by being
silent she didn't get on the floor of
the house
and talk about how this is all [ __ ]
and a lie when she knew it then
it's may 11 yesterday was may 11th
190 days after the election it took her
190 days
to get on the record on the floor and
say you're a [ __ ] liar and you're
lying to on the american people
and as soon as she did a day later they
they kicked her out as the conference
chair
but does she leave the party no does she
resign from congress no and the reason
why is because this ain't got nothing to
do with the truth
because the truth is the establishment
wants their [ __ ] party back
and if liz cheney is a way to get there
they're gonna do it
they're gonna do it because kevin
mccarthy is a bonehead
and he's obviously a trump puppet so is
scalise
and these morons like matt gatz jim
jordan lauren bobert
marjorie taylor green mo brooks louis
gohmert
list goes on and on and on with these
[ __ ] morons
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] nazi madison
cothorn all of them
all of them the list goes on and
on and on
so liz cheney staking her claim to try
to take the republican party back
because she's the one who gets their
party back guess what she gets to be
she gets to be the leader so to think
that liz cheney is not going to be in
republican leadership in the congress
again
you're you're you're just [ __ ] out of
your goddamn gourd
that's the whole point of this is for
the trumpies to vote her out
so that way she has a reason to be the
leader because she's not them
see they voted me out i'm not them be on
my
side because when it comes to the truth
when it comes to the truth being against
trump is an
easy way to look like you're a ally of
the truth
it's an easy [ __ ] way and it's
beginning to get easier and easier and
easier with this bonehead
with this nonsense again with these q
and on wackadoos like
lynn wood and mike lindell out there
selling this just
complete [ __ ] delusion that somehow
trump is the president mike lindell said
that
somehow the american people are going to
force the supreme court to overturn the
election which
that is not how that works it's an
appellate court you
you have to [ __ ] seek an appeal not
the supreme court is an appellate court
not a not a [ __ ]
they do not have a magic wand where they
get to anoint someone king
and and again they don't give a [ __ ]
about the constitution they don't give a
[ __ ] about democracy they don't give a
[ __ ] about republic
and that's why liz cheney and the
republicans know that's not sustainable
it's not sustainable they can't sustain
this garbage
because everything trump touches turns
to liquid [ __ ]
absolute 100 full stop liquid [ __ ]
[ __ ] everything the whole [ __ ] in
caboodle
i mean all's we're seeing all we're
seeing now is what we saw in the night
the early 1990s when he bankrupt casinos
how the [ __ ] do you bankrupt a casino
well how do you destroy the party of
lincoln while you're looking at it
you're looking at it so pay attention
folks so again
because uh i i i i got some grief from
um
uh another twitter account bad company
and i like bad company
we get along really good on twitter we
have a lot of the same ideas
but bad company said that it was
necessary for
for this to happen and i believe that i
i believe exactly what he's saying we're
on the same page
i'm just in the paragraph on that page
that is marked cynical
because i do not [ __ ] believe for one
goddamn second that liz cheney is doing
this for the truth
if she was doing this for the truth she
would have said the truth a long time
ago
months ago she would have been on the
floor talking about the truth
and using her microphone and using the
record
to talk about the truth now on may 11th
she talks about the truth
on the floor of the house well excuse me
so there's you another shout out the bad
company all the people out there that
follow bad company go follow bad company
and patriot takes
there's some more shout outs not that
what i say give matters a [ __ ]
difference
but i did do a tick tock on this today
on liz cheney
and those son of a [ __ ] over there
they silenced my video
like immediately it was i i don't know
what i said
it so i say the word nazi i say daddy
dick in it
um so i'm not sure exactly
what the words are that i use that they
silenced that thing but i mean i posted
it
and like boom immediately immediately
tic toc turned the sound off on that
[ __ ]
and that's usually what they do to me
they usually don't take a video down
they just turn my sound off
you know because my sound is colorful
but the the good news is is when i do
post on tick tock i have it
automatically download to my phone
so i had the video so i posted it on
twitter and i i have a copy of the video
so
[ __ ] em but
so i wanna play that tick tock for you
and then kind of break down a few more
things in there i've already done some
of that today
and maybe we won't go a full hour today
uh let's see where are we at what's
what's our time at we're at 27 minutes
now uh
you know maybe i'll be able to talk
about this for another hour i would like
to talk about one more subject but let's
play this tick tock video
this the silenced video on tick tock i
mean you can go on twitter and listen to
it or
now you'll be able to go on youtube and
listen to the son of a [ __ ]
because here it'll be so let's talk
about let's listen and we'll talk about
it on the other side
190 [ __ ] days let's talk
yesterday liz cheney decides to go to
the floor of the house and tell the
american people
that she doesn't believe in the big lie
today those weak ass republicans in the
house conference vote heard the [ __ ] out
secret ballot huh sounds like you're
scared of cheney not trump you weak
[ __ ] jesus [ __ ] crap
the big lie is not this election fraud
[ __ ] it's
trump in the big lie where the [ __ ] were
you when this [ __ ] grabber got the
nomination for your party back in 2016.
liz about during the first impeachment
during the barisma lie
but in 2020 when that dumb [ __ ] was
spreading truckloads of horseshit
about the pandemic and killed hundreds
of thousands of americans
last november or december when biden
clearly kicked trump's ass and his nazi
foot soldiers went on and on and on
about voting machines and fake ballots
don't be confused this is not a moral
troop crusade from liz cheney
this is the republicans trying to get
their party back it's good for america
and i can't wait for daddy dick to
invite these ninja poops hunting
[ __ ] them so i don't know exactly the
words that uh
that got me in trouble over on tick tock
and got the video
silence uh maybe maybe it was the
the nazis you know they don't like that
word
uh no one likes that word but i like
that word because it's very colorful
word it's a very descriptive word it
puts a lot of images in your head
uh it and it may have been the daddy
dick comment so let's start there
uh because a lot of people were alluding
to that on uh
on twitter and and tic tac and elsewhere
that
that uh that dick cheney
maybe he had something maybe he had
something to do this which i don't doubt
that
i don't doubt that liz janey and dick
cheney uh talk several times a day on
the phone
uh to think that dick cheney still
doesn't have his little tentacles inside
the republican party
you you you were not paying attention
when dick cheney was the vice president
of the united states
and to act like dick cheney was just
just in republican politics from the
year 2000 on
uh but because he was the vice president
is bone-headed too dick cheney goes all
the way back to the nixon administration
he's one of the ones that wasn't
prosecuted during the nixon
administration for [ __ ] sake
so dick cheney the cheney's had their
tentacles inside republican politics for
[ __ ] decades
decades they don't want to let their
party go why would they
so they're going to do everything they
can do to fight for it
but you know the old incident where dick
cheney was
bird hunting and he shot his friend in
the face on
accident you know allegedly it was an
accident
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna accuse
anyone of anything
but uh you know yeah i i could i could
be
all for dick cheney inviting uh some of
these republicans out there to take a
hunting trip you know i
would be against uh you know hearing
hearing a story like that it make for
good
good entertainment that the story
uh the other thing in the video that i
haven't talked about yet that i do want
to talk about and and this is an
indication of why i think
that uh these republicans aren't scared
of trump that they're actually
they're they're turning and they're
they're beginning to see that this is
unsustainable
is that they had a voice vote on this so
they didn't want to go on the record of
who voted against her
or for her depending on which way you
look at it
meaning they just did a voice foot now
now everyone kind of knows you know when
they're in the room and it's a caucus
they know amongst themselves who voted
for what and who voted for who
but there's no record of who voted so
there's no
accountability in the public of who
voted for
and who voted against and really you
were voting for
trump or against cheney here because
that's the beautiful part about this
folks that's why this is so great
is because they're they're literally
they're their own enemies
they're their own enemies i mean when's
the last time you heard any of these
boneheads bitching about barack obama
not a god i mean it's been [ __ ]
months
it's been months and it it's becoming
more and more difficult for them to even
attack
biden i mean today the fox news their
headline was battered biden
that's the best they got battered biden
he's not even
he's not even sleepy joe anymore he's a
boxer in a fight and he's just getting
beat
up a little bit getting punched in the
nose a couple times
but he's still fighting that's the best
they got
that's the best they got when is the
last time they attacked barack obama
i don't remember i can't remember the
last time
something was obama's fault
so i mean they're they're really losing
touch of of their enemy because
their enemy is inside their party and it
is kind of uh
kind of rich that the uh the party of
of against cancel culture
and that they hate cancelled culture and
they think cancer culture is the the
number one enemy of the
of of our republic and the number one
inner enemy of our country
this is going to destroy our country
when we don't have dr
seuss books or potato heads with dicks
on them
we don't have a mr potato head with
genitalia
they're the parties that are trying to
boycott coke the mlb and they're
canceling liz cheney
give me a [ __ ] break they don't
believe any of that garbage
again they don't believe any of this
[ __ ]
that's why i have a hard time believing
not being cynical about this
liz cheney thing
totally cynical because i believe that
liz cheney has the motive
of grabbing power not not truth
it just so happens that she's grabbing
power from trump
and the easiest way to be against trump
is to be for the truth
i mean good lord why do you think why do
you think he yeah
why do you think joe biden got eight
million more votes people
joe biden did not get that 81 million
votes
i'll agree with trumpers on this he did
not
there was not 81 million people that
voted for
joe biden 81 million people
voted against trump
that's what happened that's what will
continue to happen
that's why i that this whack-a-doo
q-anon stuff is unsustainable
and it won't it won't work
so let's go to some comments here i want
to read whatever there's a lot of
comments here
today see if anyone's got a question
here uh someone's talking about gas
lighting
uh yeah you know they love the gas
um and i believe that that the speech
from liz cheney
uh even though it's the truth she's
gaslighting these republicans and and by
republicans i don't mean the politicians
i think liz cheney in that speech was
talking specifically to voters
who voted for donald trump twice and
then after the insurrection
and after this just barrage of lies and
nonsense about dominion and voting
machines and
fake ballots i really truly believe
that these republican voters
the voters are [ __ ] just tired of
this garbage
they're tired of it they want to get
back to talking about high taxes
they want to start they want to get back
to talking about welfare queens and lazy
people
i mean it's evident the last few weeks
they've been talking about how no one
wants to work because of unemployment
checks
and i'll talk about that here in a
second that is a subject i wanted to
touch today
liz cheney be a presidential contender
in 24. yeah absolutely she'll be i think
that's what she's trying to do is
possibly uh
mount a presidential run or something of
the sort
something of the sort either that or
maintain her congressional seat and
become the speaker of the house or the
minority leader
i really think that's that's where she's
headed here it's it's not it's not for
the country folks
cheney's don't do much for the country
it's for them party first republican way
that's why they elected donald trump in
the first place
they didn't elect him because they
thought it was a good idea it was
because they wanted to keep power and
they seen that he had a movement and
they went with it
here we are everything he touches turns
the liquid [ __ ]
so let's talk about this um
this idea because i i'm hearing this a
lot
i'm hearing this an awful lot out there
i'm i'm seeing it posted i've actually
heard people say it in my ear
that uh well the reason why
the reason why we have people not
working
is because people are making too much
money
living off the government this
unemployment is way too
high and the people are living off the
government
i've heard it from a few friends of mine
now and then a few friends of mine
have been talking about how they've been
hearing it from other people which they
don't believe it but they hear from
other people
this is all a bunch of horse [ __ ] that
somehow someone wants to
live off the government well the problem
that we have with labor right now is
there's a couple different problems i
think
number one that pandemic
proved a lot to people who don't make a
living wage in this country
the first thing that the pandemic proved
to these people
is that the government does have the
money and the government can't afford it
mean we spent a [ __ ] load of money
people a [ __ ] load of money
paying corporations businesses and
individuals
and stimulus checks and ppp
and cash straight cash
we spent a lot of money and we haven't
had the stock market crash
yet i mean remember when biden was elect
going to be elected the stock market was
going to crash it hasn't crashed
and just gone up i don't know that that
necessarily is a great thing
the bigger they are the harder they fall
the point is
is that the government people realize
the government can't afford it
here's the other thing people realized
when they got their unemployment checks
when they were unemployed to no fault of
their own
if they were making more money on the
unemployment the federal assistance
unemployment with the state and the
federal assistance
that federal part of the check
if they were making more money than they
were making waiting tables or whatever
that whatever their job was
it was probably a a a minimum wage type
job you know people consider it medial
but these aren't menial jobs jesus
christ these were essential workers
essential workers but they realized
that they're not that far from a livable
wage here's what i mean
that it only takes a couple hundred more
bucks a week and a couple or
more hundred bucks a month for them to
feel financially secure
and they thought well [ __ ] if that's all
it takes if that's all it really takes
they got a taste of that
of some sort of security that they could
pay their bills and they could buy
food and have a little bit of scratch
left over that it wasn't that far away
from them
it felt like the minimum wage and the
job that they had was keeping them under
that
that point and some people had to find a
[ __ ] job in the meantime
so they did the things that they had to
do to make a job to pay better
so why should they have to come back and
serve your dumb ass cheeseburgers
and take [ __ ] from cairns all day
who want their [ __ ] food served to
him
like a master get out of here the [ __ ]
out of here
the biggest thing that the pandemic
revealed
is that rich people in this country are
not the job creators
they're not that's all [ __ ]
that's all ronald reagan supply side
trickle down
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] lie it's the lie
that liz
cheney wants to sell to you by the way
that's the lie she wants to sell to you
not the big lie about the election she
wants the big lie about how
rich people are the [ __ ] job creators
because if you don't believe me if you
don't believe me that rich people are
not the job creators
go ask go ask the rich [ __ ]
that own the movie theaters
ask those those job creators how many
jobs they had during the pandemic
i'm gonna tell you who the job creators
are and most of you folks already know
this because most you folks are not
boneheads
and if you are a bonehead out there
listen to me turn up the [ __ ] volume
turn the volume up
job creators are customers
that's who creates jobs ask the movie
theaters ask the restaurants
the movie theaters didn't fire all their
employees because the rich people
were out of money they fired the
employees because they had no customers
no customers equals no [ __ ] jobs
that's how it works it's called
capitalism
that's how it works and people realize
that this [ __ ] rich people are job
creators [ __ ] is all [ __ ] [ __ ]
all of it the full hall the whole
[ __ ] line of his [ __ ]
the other thing that they discovered is
that essential worker the people who are
actually keeping the economy going
the essential workers are getting [ __ ]
by the so-called job creators that's why
people are mad
so if you think they're mad and they're
staying at home because they get an
unemployment check
you're a [ __ ] idiot
i mean chipotle a corporation is
announcing that
they're probably going to be raising
their minimum wage to 15
an hour nationwide i mean we're going to
get to 15
an hour without even having to do it at
the federal government because in
capital
capitalist society businesses have to
compete for labor
you compete for it
you don't just get [ __ ] labor it's
not [ __ ] we're not [ __ ] slaves in
this country
well sort of we shouldn't have to be
but when it seems like that when it
seems like that
attitudes are going to change so as
these companies start to compete for
labor
when they actually start to compete for
labor like they did
in the late 40s and the 50s and i'll
explain that here in a minute
when they compete for the labor then
they'll have plenty of people to work
for them
this [ __ ] about how oh i can't find
anyone to work for me
no you can't find anyone to work for you
for what your
the pittance you're willing to pay [ __ ]
that's why you don't have any workers
because you're not willing to pay what
they're worth
so until you start paying what they're
worth you're not gonna get much [ __ ]
help
[Music]
so pony up the dough and compete for
labor
because it's gonna cost more now that's
how it's gonna work
so sorry i
had a big unemployment soap box there
that was on
but you know if they compete for this
labor
and we get this market back going i
believe we're going to have 18 to 24
months of one of the biggest economic
booms that we've seen in the last 40
years
it's gonna be huge if we can get these
morons to finally
be convinced that they're gonna have to
compete for our labor
because the the the minimum wage
part of society is not going to put up
with
not getting paid what they're worth
anymore and when that happens
all boats will rise
when the people who have the least have
more and can spend
more and can participate more in the
economy
we'll be better off and so will the
economy it's called
capitalism learn it
it's these self-proclaimed [ __ ] free
market capitalists don't even know what
capitalism is
so back to the point
where we talk about competing for labor
in the 1940s the late 40s and the 50s
after the second world war it was
booming over here
booming we were building [ __ ] cars were
rolling off refrigerators there was all
kinds of [ __ ] we were selling
all kinds of [ __ ] and factories were
rolling stuff off the lines like crazy
and these employers mainly factories
couldn't find enough
workers and the reason why they couldn't
find enough workers is because
the factory down the road was paying
more
so they had to compete for that labor
so they either paid them more hourly or
in a salary
or what they did is they gave them
benefits that's actually how our country
came to have
employer-based health care
which at the time seemed like a smart
thing to do it sucks
now but at the time it was the thing to
do
number one the health care didn't cost
near as much
there wasn't as much health care frankly
and the employers could give you an
actual pension plan
you know the word pension and actual
pension
because what could happen is it could go
on investment and the company wouldn't
have to fork over that money until much
later
but it was a benefit that that person
received for working at that job
so not only were they competing
companies were competing
for the actual price of the labor they
were competing with benefits
to try to get people to come work for
them
that's the moment we're in now these
companies have
to compete for us americans to come work
for them
that's what's happening that's a
struggle we're having in the economy
with labor
and that's why we have a employer-based
health care system
which we need to uncouple and make it to
where employers can compete without that
component now
because then it was easy now it's
it's difficult difficult it's it's a
horrible [ __ ] system in the economy
that we have now that we built
on the back of employer-based healthcare
we have much more people much more
health care procedures they're much more
expensive
it is not a good idea that's a whole
nother [ __ ] podcast
a whole nother podcast but this idea
that people are staying home
and staying home because they're getting
their government check
and it's more than than when what they
can make working at their old job
what does that tell you what does that
tell you it doesn't tell me that they're
lazy
it tells me that they they're worth more
money
so compete for their [ __ ] labor you
free market capitalist
investor job creators you [ __ ]
we're at 48 minutes now so i almost made
it to an hour
but before i leave you know i do this
every time i want to thank you guys for
for coming and and listening to me yell
and scream into a microphone for an hour
on wednesdays
at three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern every [ __ ] week this is
episode 18.
god damn we almost got a two in front of
it now
18 weeks we've been doing this show
i love every minute of it and i'm so
glad that you guys join me and
we're getting more subscribers on
youtube uh and i'm getting
more and more followers on twitter every
single day
and i'm glad you guys like my content uh
and and
really uh i appreciate all the comments
today
uh there's brandy out there uh ajac
abroad
uh john fitzgerald was commenting i
don't want to leave anyone out chris was
there so
i thank you guys for coming in and
commenting if i didn't get to your
comments
uh i love you guys and i'm glad that you
can come and
and support me here and if you want to
support the podcast
because it does cost money to publish
the podcast and do that sort of thing
feel free to do that you can go to
thetonymichaels.com we got hats for sale
we had troy last week he bought several
hats and i
shipped them to them so troy you're
listening i hope you got your hats
and then now you we also got a merch
store that's got some [ __ ] stickers
everyone likes to [ __ ] them
so we got [ __ ] stickers we got coffee
mugs over there if you guys want to
support me that way i have a patreon but
i
really haven't been hawking that thing
maybe we'll do that in the future
but so if you want to support the
podcast financially uh to help us with
the publishing fees and some of the
software that we use
some of those costs that would be
fantastic that would help us out so any
of the money we get from hats or merch
or any of that stuff
goes towards the podcast to pay for all
that great stuff
that way i can keep yelling into the
microphone and yelling into the tick
tock and yelling into the twitter for
you guys
so you guys have all these great
arguments that you can go and
slap on your your trumpian friends so
thank you thank you so much for uh for
joining me today
and we'll see you next week uh
at three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern same place
we stream on youtube we stream on
twitter live
you can find it on youtube after we've
streamed
on the channel just go to
thetonymichaels.com it'll take you to
the youtube channel
you also can download this podcast
after we're done on apple podcast and
spotify it's on those it's on several
other channels if you go to buzz sprout
just go to the tonymichaels.com or go to
the app store
the the apple podcast or their spotify
you can find it there
just search let's talk the tony michaels
podcast and until next week
until next week [ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them